okay let me make a start so this session
is about our plans for education and
particularly global education reform
particularly probably more discussing a
high school and college per se although
I think what we're talking about
actually is reflected in both but I
think the sort of issues I want to cover
are perhaps more prevalent as problems
in in particular in high schools than
there at least in some levels of college
so really I want to talk about several
things I want to wear out a vision for
what's wrong in particular with math I
want to about some of the progress we've
made in executing to fix that vision and
some of the plans we have but we haven't
yet executed the thing that strikes me
and has struck me for a number of years
now is kind of Wolfram's at the center
of STEM education as nobody else it's
quite hard to find another organization
on the planet that interact particularly
with math but you could say more general
in more generality with stem in as many
ways as we do and you know i mean what i
mean by that is so we built computation
stuff as you know we hire people who are
technical we we interact with you know
10 million people around the world in
different ways who are technical which
is you know big fraction of sort of
serious technical people at some level
yeah in virtually every kind of you know
since connection with math there we are
and that gives us a rather unique
perspective on the story of math around
the world and the story of math in the
real world and I'm going to argue that
in fact you give us a broader
perspective than pretty much anyone else
on the planet from which to to
understand what to do so the perspective
we have I think is one that if we're not
going to make some of the changes I'm
talking about nobody else will or at
least it's harder for them to get that
vision in which case and also execute on
some of these changes the other thing
obviously is we have our own technology
to implement what I'm talking about in
now I separate these two because I don't
think some of the things I'm talking
about you know necessitate that we have
to use our own technology although of
course we believe we've built the best
technology to do that so but they are
separate kinds of issues look when I
talk about the curriculum particularly
the math curriculum I think there are
two quite separate plans but operate in
our organization in a sense and I think
this is perfectly sensible and realistic
the obvious plan that most other
organizations who are anywhere near this
field when operating is how do we take
today's curriculum and support it as
well as we can right so even if the
curriculum is dumb in some way how do we
give the best tools give the best
support and improve the pedagogy improve
the delivery with all the things that we
do and you know that that's a very
rational thing and we want to do that
and that's where you can immediately get
results and we have been and many of you
are involved in that and have been for
many years with our software the other
thing which I particularly been worrying
about in the last few years and much of
this talk will be about is how do we
lead the replacement and that's really
what I wanted to focus on and there are
a lot of topics that come in to both of
these directions there's coding there's
assessment there's modern delivery and
there's what what I'm going to talk
about now which is computer based math
this this this idea of fundamentally
changing the math curriculum so let me
spend a good fraction next time what I
was going to do is spend some time
talking through this and I hope lever a
fair time for discussion and and
reflection on on how we move forward um
let me start by saying one good thing if
you're into math math is high on the
agenda around the world right as never
as it never has been before like more
people fuss about math I mean
government's edgy you know educators
themselves industry everybody you think
of sort of all walks of life are fussing
about math you know most of the fact
that nobody can do it or not enough
people can do it all the P
who can do it can't do it well enough or
they can't apply it or any of the
associated problems but in the end most
people realize that our economies are
are very dependent on technical people
and technical people for their training
a very dependent on math and it's not
really working now so the good news is
math the thing called math is high on
the agenda the bad news is that I'm
going to argue about eighty percent of
it's the wrong subject so we've got a
thing that's called math that people are
all excited about which is great the
problem is what they're excited about is
largely the wrong thing I think although
painting them over that way of thinking
I think is not impossible in fact it
there's a lot of its confusion so what
am I talking about well I think I she'd
this story the suddenly went British on
me i guess i have math vs maths here cuz
they for some reason when you cross the
atlantic you lose the ass um the young
whoops you know why that didn't activate
her on them like that we go so though
we've gone back to America math in the
real world if you look at it and what
many of you guys do is you take problems
you model them you use the calculating
of a computer and you're trying to take
the real world and use math to problem
solve in the real world in education it
looks pretty different it typically
looks something like this you write
stuff down you look at endless problems
that have seemed completely abstracted
from anything you might actually do and
if you're very very lucky use a TI
calculator so this doesn't seem to match
very well so i'm going to argue that the
fundamental problem with math education
around the world that exists right now
is you know in the real world most of
the time you're taking problems and
you're solving them you know using
whatever the best machinery is to do the
computing of solving those problems your
problem solving using the system of
maths but you're using a computer do the
calculating in education about eighty
percent of the time is spent learning
how to do the calculating by hand in a
sense mimicking the computer you know
and that leaves about twenty percent for
doing the real problem solving
methodology
and it also causes all sorts of other
problems and in intense that is the
fundamental mismatch around the world
that has those happened over the last 50
years and is getting worse my argument
is unless you fix that you aren't going
to have maths that work so let's dive
into that a little bit more and talk
about why that might be let's talk about
why people learn maths in the first
place or actually a slightly different
topic which is why is maths one of these
general subjects that everyone in the
world is supposed to learn there aren't
many subjects in that category right
there is most people's own language I
guess English or I maybe I should call
it American if you're here there is
history most people are thought they
should learn history of some sort and
this kind of math I mean that you know
you can argue a few others but basically
it's in one of those very very
mainstream subjects now I think there
are you know three reasons for everyone
to learn math if it's the right math and
the reasons are basically is technical
jobs which have so driven our economies
in the last well arcs in the last 50
years but but you arguably much longer
than that what I call everyday living
the ability just a function in a modern
world requires much more quantitative
approach than it did when we launched
Mathematica 26 27 years ago I'm thirdly
what we might call logical mind training
the ability to think now I mean you can
call this several this third one you can
characterize this other ways but
basically the idea is is there a
structure that you understand you'll be
able to think through problems whether
there are explicitly mathematical
problems or not if it's a business
problem do you have some way to hang off
your reasoning so those are three
reasons I think it's good to learn the
right math let's now talk about what is
math so I think math is basically a
process of four steps the first thing
you're doing is you're defining a
question and the question may be rather
fuzzy to start with you know the
question might be if this room is sealed
and we're all in here how long can we
live hopefully I'm not going to test
that
the the next thing is take that problem
and turn it into abstract math right so
that's quite a hard step usually so what
that means is what why do you do this
the reason you do this is because
abstraction allows you to have many many
different problems that have a very
similar structure of sort of set up so
what that means is if you've got those
problems though we've spent hundreds of
years designing mathematics be able to
take that problem that question and turn
it into an answer if it's in that
abstract form so that's what gives you
the power the abstraction gives you a
lot of the power be able to take this
fuzzy problem and turn it into an answer
so step two is translate it from the
real world to math step three years
compute the answer turn the question to
the answer and in this abstract form
step four is take the answer in the
abstract form and go back to the real
world did it answer the question what's
the number how long can we all survive
in here right it's a number we're
looking for and if the number comes out
as minus ten something was wrong so
that's kind of what you're doing pretty
much in every math problem now here's
the problem the problem is that this
step three so in the current curriculum
step three is basically predominating
with hand calculating and yet that's a
step that essentially nobody does above
basic levels or you know around some
edge cases nobody does by hand anymore
in the real world so why on earth are we
doing that endlessly in education for
most of the time people getting educated
and you know what we should be doing is
using computers for step three almost
universally and we should be using
students for much more of step 1 2 & 4
and in a nutshell that is the problem of
the world's math education another way
to look at this this is our CBM helix of
math and you know you can also think of
going through these steps as going up a
helix and as you go out the helix you go
through these but then when you get to
the interpret step it may be that you
discover that actually well you know the
interpretation means that you go to go
around and do the problem again until
you refine it sufficiently to get to an
answer that you think matches the kind
of level of accuracy that you want
so that's kind of what you're doing in
the math process and by the way we have
a poster of this that is downstairs that
tries to map this out that I'm hoping
will get hung in more and more
classrooms so people have some
visualization of what they're actually
doing it's amazing that if you ask
people in most classrooms what are you
doing in math it's just a big fog and
including most teachers so I'm arguing
math is a much bigger subject than
calculating and Stan obviously is a I
mean by definition is a is a broader
subject than math and if you confuse
those two you get into all sorts of
difficulties let me just to make this
you know obvious but for this crowd but
just to make this concrete this is a
standard you know linear simultaneous
equation that you would learn at school
and do by hand no doubt but as we all
know we can you know just change it and
make something more complicated by
making it a cubic and the thing is
fundamentally what you're doing there
the concept of an equation isn't
important thing to understand so the
concept the idea that you might have an
equation that might be a tool you might
use is very important but whether it
happens to be linear what happens to be
cubic it's kind of to the side it's a
separate issue and whether you happen to
know how to solve a linear one but not a
cubic one shouldn't be the main thing
predominating in whether you use
equations to solve problems or to try
and make the problem linear when it
really isn't linear because you couldn't
solve the cubic because you had to do it
by hand and of course one can make it
even worse than this right because if
you do your Syria example but let me go
back so I remember i did and say solve x
cubed plus two equals 2y + y minus x
equals 5 and siri willing and everything
else we will hopefully get the answer
courtesy of i'm going to show this on
the screen here courtesy of wolf Malph
of course through Siri and he's trying
the line this correctly shown some
reason my brain is not aligning the
reflection but you know you've got a
seriously ask given that I've managed to
do that by talking to my phone and solve
a cubic simultaneous equation you know
if you take that equation and give it to
most people after they've studied math
for 12 years of their life they won't be
able to do it so you've got a seriously
ask why we're trying to
train them for 12 is there life to do
something I can talk to my phone in 20
seconds and get done when they can't
even achieve it after that time there's
obviously a problem there and it's funny
because I've done that demo for actually
groups of ministers of education things
around the world and they're all like oh
yes you've got a point we never thought
about that before um so another thing I
want to talk about is when we think
about the curriculum right now it's
labeled by in a sense the mechanics of
what's inside this seems a dumb way to
label something you know if you label
how you drive your car for example by
well you know there's the it's kind of
like you drive your car by knowing how
the seats are made it doesn't seem to
match and to some extent you know
labeling things by you know inverting
matrices or simplifying surds which I
particularly hate it or whatever doesn't
seem the right way to sort of head your
curriculum what you should be doing in
my view is heading it with problems that
invoke all sorts of different bits of
math because in the end that's what
you're going to have to do in life so
you know designer currency what coins
notes do you need by how many levels of
friends you separated by on facebook
what you know making a perfect password
for your login the problem of every six
year old today so their friends making
their account what's a beautiful shape
that's a perfectly relevant mathematical
question the Greeks considered it why
shouldn't we um and you know things
which of course you can ask but couldn't
ever imagine doing in in the old world
you know how much by how much can you
compress a photo or video or music
before you notice again a problem that
we all have I mean you know should you
should you save the 256k edition of your
music or should you save some different
editions should you compress your photos
but you know you can actually of course
start playing with these things and
figuring out what it is your what these
things mean in reality what changing the
algorithm actually does in different
cases and so forth these are real maths
questions of today so my argument about
what we're trying to do with CBM
so-called is um in the sense that is the
I guess this is the logic you know if
math is for all students so if you're
assuming if you're going to argue that
math is a general-purpose subject and
not some niche subject like ancient
Greek
then that implies that math in education
has two more or less match math in the
real world and if you which it implies
that math and education should be the
kind of math I'm talking about I mean
that's basically as pretty pretty much
as as bold as that you know there are
various mathematicians who argue to me
on a no but there's this long history of
math and loaded are the problem with
that is in the end if it's only relevant
to you know one percent of the
population that's great it's great if
people want to go study that subject
it's a good subject just like ancient
Greek is a good subject problem is you
can't justify it for everyone it doesn't
make any sense and I'm going to argue
that today's math is also largely a
proxy for math so what do I mean by that
well it's a bit like Latin I guess in
the u.s. you didn't typically learn loud
in Britain I learned Latin actually but
Latin is sort of degenerated in terms of
well I guess it's the same as it was a
thousand years ago something but it's
degenerate in terms of one's a level of
which one learns it now it may be I mean
I think the reason I was taught Latin
though I never discovered in 10 years I
think the reason I was taught Latin was
so I learnt English grammar at least
that was one reason it may be that
learning English grammar by learning
Latin is a perfectly reasonable thing to
do maybe that's a better way of teaching
me English grammar than just learning
English grammar but it does seem to me
that your starting point ought to be if
if the end results you want is to learn
English grammar then that's probably the
starting assumption you should use that
you should teach English grammar right
similarly if you want to learn real math
it seems to me that you should start
from the idea that lets mimic the math
in the real world and take that into the
classroom and use the real math to learn
rather than some proxy that apparently
may have existed 50 years ago but
actually doesn't get used in the same
way and is some really quite different
subjects so that's an argue night sighs
you know you've got to learn how to do
your quadratic equation by hand if you
want to learn how to problem solve with
math you've got to learn Latin if you
want to learn English grammar maybe I
don't really buy it a nice particular
fact i would buy it more for latin
frankly than i do plug this
another haunted also contrasts his math
vs coding coding has become a sort of in
thing starting i think in estonia moving
to the UK and now here and percolating
out to various other countries um some
reason the english-speaking thing first
maybe because all the languages of words
it took me in english i don't know um I
do think coding is important but for a
different reason for most governments
most governments think codings good
because people make apps they haven't
quite got further than understanding why
that is I think the reason codings
importance because it's the way you
write down math if you have a technical
idea in the modern world the way you
write it down is to write code realistic
now in the olden world one way you wrote
this down was to write mathematical
abstraction no you wrote algebra
algebraic expressions and you can still
do that the problem of that is it's sort
of only a partial that there are only
certain things you can abstract
expressions the much more general thing
you can do is to extract a code because
code covers all sorts of cases that
expressions don't cover and in practice
that's what you do right because you
want a computer to run it so I would
argue the reason code is crucial is so
you can write down technical ideas and
it's in a sense the equivalent of
handwriting as it was to English you
know in the olden world handwriting was
crucial because no other way to write
your ideas down and you learnt it in
English you know when you were at school
in primary school even though used it in
history and math everything else I think
coding actually should be part of the
primary maths curriculum because i think
it's sort of the same relationship so in
a sense the weather thing about is math
as a system of problem solving a system
of doing stem and light coding is a way
to express math and of course
particularly we have our Wolfram
language which i think is highly
expressive and has math built into it so
that kind of links to in a very very
nice way that hasn't really done before
now here's a point I'd like to make to
people if you remove the computer you
remove the context and this is a point
that I think is perhaps the most crucial
point about this argument that is
completely missed by curriculum setting
authorities
so the key point is here that you know
the reason math is so important in the
real world today is because it's applied
in so many disparate areas represented
many of them at this conference it's
applied in biology it's applied in mass
data in all sorts of places it is also
blind traditional places like physics
it's applied in art it's applied in
ophthalmology watching back there uh-huh
yeah it's applied in all these places
that was not true 50-plus years ago it
didn't get applied in many of these
areas because didn't work the reality of
it is map didn't work very well in
anywhere that need is mass computation
like anything required data for example
just didn't work because the male's and
mechanized computing mechanized
computing has allowed math to be applied
in same place so the very thing that has
made governments panic about math
because the reason math is so important
to governments and others around the
world it's because it's so applicable to
so many things which is driving
economies and jobs and people's lives
and so forth so that very reason why
it's become so important in the real
world is being locked out of education
because we're telling people you are not
allowed to use computers to do the
computation and so my argument here is
if you remove the computer from mass
education you are removing almost all of
the real context you can't do real
biology problems in math in education if
you don't have a computer mathematically
you can't do them because you have mass
data it doesn't make any sense you can
do it with 10 data points but that's
different so by removing the cut the
computer you remove the context and
people see through this students and
teachers will understand that the
problems are being given I basically
don't make any sense because they're not
real they're not real because they get
can't do math computation there are
things you can change in reordering the
curriculum so here's a very simple
example you know why don't we teach
thermodynamics at primary school the
basic idea of thermodynamics you know is
fairly simple you know the more atoms
we've gone in a box basically other
things being equal the higher the
pressure right if you change the
container to a smaller container the
pressure goes up
you know etc etc there all sorts of
things you can play but the basic ideas
here that the feel you can get is
something that I think comes fairly
naturally here's another thing this
comes from some Estonia model to a well
in a bit um this was a nice example we
have where we split the class into and
the idea is that some of them toss coins
actually do 200 coin tosses note down
their results and the other half cheat
by just typing in heads and tails to the
computer right and the question is can
the teacher tell who's cheatin who
actually did the experiment and the
answer is yes typically so my cheat here
you'll see that I only pass one of the
five tests are on this set of data and
so I pretty much concluded that I
cheated and the kids are actually amazed
by this right it's like how can the
teacher tell hoochie didn't who didn't
cheat and actually just to show you this
if i can get this right i could guess do
a something like um i guess i could let
me let me semi not cheat so i'm going to
generate 200 i'm going to generate 200m
coin tosses but because we're using our
nice around the number generator I guess
I don't um you know I I don't know where
this is cheating or not but um let me
paste that into here it'sit's zeros and
ones a set of heads and tails but I
think it'll cope and you'll see here
that in fact that case past it all five
tests so that's sort of what would have
happened if they done the coin toss
really except I semi cheated um no so
this leads into fraud detection right i
mean this is the basic idea you're
looking for patterns in data can you
figure out where the patterns real or
not real whether it's a cheat or not a
cheat cetera et cetera et cetera this is
a powerful thing but it's actually quite
Amina multi at a young age so you can
reorder the curriculum if you think this
way now just to be very clear what I'm
talking about right now is a
computer-based not computer-assisted so
what do I mean computer-based means take
the real subject
apply a computer in education just as
you would in the real subject to
actually do the calculator what I mean
my computer assisted is what mostly has
happened around the world which is take
the computer and use it as a pedagogical
aid or replacement even for the teacher
in some way that works with the
traditional subject or maybe not I mean
I'm not saying you can't multiply these
two together I think you need computer
assisted to a deliver computer it but
computer-assisted I mean the delivery
but it's no good delivering the wrong
subject that's the point and it's kind
of like however well you deliver the
wrong subjects not going to be the right
subject and you've got to get the
subject right before you figure out how
to deliver it and I'm all for using
computers to improve the delivery
there's nothing wrong with that if they
really do okay so that's the thesis what
are we doing to make the change how far
are we got so the first thing I'm just
going to emphasize is vision for the
right subject it is amazing how little
vision that has been in math education
for years I mean see more pop out and
others had a vision and but a lot of the
problem is that everybody wants to try
and reform our education tries to think
too much about the next semester they're
so worried about getting the thing to
start that they'd lose the vision and so
everybody loses the vision and maybe
they didn't have a clear vision to start
with so one thing I think very important
one keeps the vision even if it will
take years to implement nothing is to
build the right subject so one of the
things we've been trying to work on is
what are the outcomes we actually
explicitly want from math so this is a
10 dimensional list of outcomes again
you go around the world and you ask
countries already else what you want to
achieve from 12 years of teaching
everyone math and they don't know I mean
they claim they know but it doesn't add
up what they typically tell you is you
want we want critical thinking skills
and so that's great but what does it
mean and there's another level they say
we want people to know how to put bar
you know ticks on bar charts it's like
well okay maybe that's a useful skill
maybe it isn't but it's it's somewhere
deep in the trenches you know with the
rats running around it's sort of deep
down there so what we try to do is
construct a 10 dimensional list of sort
of the outcome dimensions and you know
it's a it's an interesting list I think
its confidence tackle new problems
you know which involves their practical
things you can do knowing how to read
documentation of math for example
knowing how to teach yourself new tools
these are practical things you really
need abstracting to mathematical
concepts that's perhaps a more
traditional I'm planning and managing
the process most people leave school you
know not having the foggiest idea how
they're going to take the math they
learnt and actually using it on a real
problem it seems to me it's a crucial
thing it's like going to management and
telling you read all these books but
you're never going to talk to an
employee ever and before you get into
manage anybody you are never allowed to
do that and then you go in on day one
and you've got to manage a large company
and it's just going to fail right it's
got to fail cuz complicated you know
stuff comes up which you don't expect
things don't react like you like you
were told they would people don't react
that way um so you know those are all
important things interpreting critiquing
verifying generalizing models
communicating collaborating those are
perhaps more obvious this is an
interesting one so the idea of an
equation or a matrix the concept of the
equation of the matrix isn't the same
thing as the detailed equation solving
or inverting of the matrix right one is
a concept of a tool and the other one is
the actual tool itself and how you how
you use it and if you don't separate
those you're going to do big people say
you know i want i want i am a maths
curriculum want people to learn the
quadratic or what do they mean do they
mean the idea of an equation and how
you'd set it up and when you'd set it up
and how you'd use it although they mean
given that you've set the equation up
the actual detailed mechanics you'd use
to solve it they're different and it's
often the former is totally left out of
that and that's crucial because if you
don't understand when you'd use an
equation when you'd fit a curve you
understand those things it's not a lot
of use to you and instinctive feel mats
so that those are some of the things we
worked on for building the right subject
and it's very complicated you know which
bits of math what's the layering what's
the narrative around it so another thing
that our needs to be done is to align I
mean this is a long long I spray the
outer core of this problem clearly
assessment drives a lot of what happens
around the world and
the assessment is pretty goofy much of
it and is driving people to do the wrong
kind of math and so over time a key
thing of making the changes to start
aligning the assessment which is to
start to win the vision argument but
that's a slow burn for traditional
assessments but I want to come back to
non-traditional assessments which are
growing in currency I mean certainly the
UK for example the traditional
governmental back things are becoming
fairly degenerate in many respects to
the point where people are looking for
other kinds of ways to say I'm good at
this job because the traditional a
levels as we call them in the UK for
example don't particularly do that job
very well it's like when we hire people
it's like really what they did in their
a-levels doesn't tell us a hell of a lot
about whether they're going to be good
at the job frankly and I think that's
true in many countries the things have
got is disconnected another problem is
math marketing so you know getting back
in the UK because I know the example
where the government was very proud of
saying that you know long division they
were going to make everyone learn how to
do long division now and properly now I
mean apart from being damn stupid to
start with because it's unnecessary it's
all so damn bad marketing is what you're
telling students that the best thing the
most exciting thing they're going to do
in that whole maths curriculum is learn
some blasted process that the computer
should be doing anyway it doesn't seem
like a great sell so one of the things
we've got to make sure is that we
actually make math seem seem cool and
seem interesting I don't know you
probably know our computer-based maths
website where we've been trying to make
the case and make some of these things
out but I think there are there are
various things to do along that so
making the case mesh with today's ad
environment the fact of the matter is
there's a huge infrastructure of math
around the world the question is how do
you mess with that there's teachers
there's technology and they're set up
and so I think there are other good ways
and not as discrepant ways you might
think to mesh with these things and kind
of like that's another part of what we
need to do so what's the progress so far
well we found in computer-based math dot
org a few years ago and its aim is to
build a new math curriculum and to make
sure that we get that at deployed in as
many places as possible
what's the progress and also to make the
case I mean good piece of progress I
think is the discourse is starting to
change slowly but surely there is
starting to be a changer people are
starting to say you know and I've seen
in articles new york times I've seen
article there's certain plenty of things
in the UK things in other countries
saying you know what maybe we need to
look at the subject of math maybe it's
not this sort of God given subject that
arrived one day and that should never be
touched maybe there's a problem and
maybe the problems actually quite severe
so that is coming through and that is
percolating other probably progresses we
really did start to build a curriculum
this is slow going but I think we've
made quite significant progress and the
progress is several fold one of the
piece of prose is actually hardest is
sort of the frameworks what I would call
the frameworks the intellectual and
practical frameworks so what do I mean
by that well you know if you're
delivering a new subject which nobody's
ever seen before what what do you do to
manifest that how do you think about it
how do you structure it so we've
structured into things called activities
chapters topics modules and modalities
and roughly speaking activities is sort
of the the in a sense the atomic not
exactly the atomic but that the the
normal sort of currency unit what they
are is you know here's something you
want to do it's inside a storyline
that's a module and that's broken up
into chapters and there are certain
topics you need to cover and then there
are things called modalities what we
mean by modality 'he's are in a sense
the delivery mode what is it how are you
delivering that piece of the activity
what you actually have to do is it that
your teacher is lecturing you hopefully
not in most cases is it that you're
swapping data with your teacher is it
that you are you know interacting
writing a program is that the modality
so that's kind of what we mean by by
modalities and some of you know we got
our first country excited about
computer-based maths and that is Estonia
and so about last year we've been
building they wanted us to redo their
high school probability and statistics
curriculum and so we built that and we
had our first pilot that ran in the last
few months and I think was really pretty
successful across about ten percent
the estonian schools lots of stuff to
learn lots of stuff to fix but the the
overriding thing i found out of that was
that you know the teachers I mean the
biggest concern thinking the government
had was that the teachers wouldn't
manage it they actually had less
concerned the kids wouldn't manage it i
have to say they were more concerned
about the teachers um the reaction of
teachers you know it was a lot of
nervousness but actually they found it
easier than they thought to some level
because they could actually understand
what the point was what they were doing
and so could the kids and the kids had
more fun doing it and the kids actually
came out saying they thought it was
easier than some of that traditional
math but I think it's a lot harder I
mean I think if you look at the topics
their their university level topics some
of them so let me just try and fire up
just to give you a rough flavor of this
and John will talk a bit more later
about the actual insides of this so this
is what starting computer-based math in
Estonia looks like except there's an
estonian estonian version but i won't go
into that um this is the english version
so we've got a bunch of modules here
these are the module headings and there
are nine I think how many modules are
there there are 12 modules I think and
the first module is entitled am i normal
so the problem for the kids is to figure
out am i normal what what does that mean
what is the mathematics about my normal
and you know so you open up a module
like this and this is what this is the
teacher view of it so one of the things
we've ended up doing is building a whole
bunch of infrastructure you know
teachers students sharing what do we
actually deliver so this is a lesson
plan for the teacher and this is sort of
what you're going to cover and lesson
doesn't look terribly exciting but you
know we start up and everything in blue
here is only for the teacher this only
appears in the teacher version and so
here we're talking about what does
normal you know what are good ways to to
think about you know is it height is it
foot length is it what you wear you know
is that normal how are we going to
quantify this and we go through various
types of activities here which some of
which are swapped centrally in the
classroom some of which are not and I'm
not she going to do them here but you
can see that this is the sort of mode in
which which this operates and further
down you can you know
then we're trying to get them to look at
charts and to pick out interesting
things in the charts okay so when you
look at a standard chart of things what
can you what do you count as being
normal or not what's interesting about
the chart these are fuzzy questions so
this is just one example of sort of a
module just a few of the others here
proof by survey how can I convince you
to the point of how can I convince you
is to get people to look at data they're
given and to teach them the ways that
data will be gained on them so you know
the fact is when you see a graph and the
you know and the news website it's going
to have a bunt it may have a bunch of
tricks or skewing or whatever in it the
question is can they learn it so the
idea was get them to understand what how
people do this stuff so that they're not
fooled by it so here's an example to a
simple example these are mobile phone
sales data from estonia in the four
quarters of 2012 and you'll note called
a four is actually slightly smaller in
sales than called a three the question
is if you're the sales manager how would
you present this graph so that it didn't
seem like that was what was happening so
you know a standard problem now the
thing is not to you know to get folks to
understand that they should cheat all
the time but it's the fact is these are
going to be pulled on them if they're
managing the sales manager this is
something that will happen and so maybe
I'll make it 3d and I'll have this piece
closer to me and actually that already
looks like the fourth quarter here was a
little bit more promising than the third
quarter and so forth so it's a very
simple example but that's the sort of
thing that we want them to understand
because if they understand that um it'll
be easier so the student version is
quite nice because it kind of
immediately syncs with the with the
teacher version you can go fullscreen
and so forth so anyway that's a that's a
rough guide to some of the things that
we have been starting to do in Estonia
and we're also starting things in Sweden
and in African universities so what do
we got to do well we got to do the rest
of the math curriculum I think it's very
about ten percent and we've got a lot
more to although we've we've done more
activities and you might ask how it's
broken down my organ would be something
like geometry signal processing or we
need about a name for that sort of model
an architecture of maths or some other
elements as well as what I would call
this which is data science also to do is
to consumer eyes right now we're setting
us up for classrooms and governments and
all these things but actually you know
we would like to be able to just deliver
this to individual parents and teachers
we just aren't ready yet it's too
open-ended we haven't quite got there I
don't think it's easy enough to
understand at this stage the other big
question which I have is should we be
going into the assessment market you
know a zillion people have told me you
guys should start running math
assessments why it seems just crazy to
me okay why why are people saying
they're saying well because people might
believe that math assessment the wolf
and ran was worth something and was the
right thing so I don't know I'd be
interested in your views on whether
that's a useful direction for us I mean
one of the things I want to do is
establish assessment that actually
actually makes some sense and also to do
is sort of coding education now coding
as I said as a prerequisite and we have
been working a bit on that in coding and
the programming lab and Adriana was just
going to just explain the programming
lab that we've been working on and give
you a quick demo of that hi everyone you
hear me ok um so like Connor said my
name is Adriana O'Brien I'm working with
the team developing the Wolfram
programming lab and you saw a brief view
of this earlier in the keynote what the
Wolfram programming lab is is really
focused on making a safe environment for
learners we're not only do they get
access to the Wolfram language but they
also get access to these activities
these activities are called explorations
and they're interdisciplinary so you can
get computation across all subject areas
so here's one called word ladders and as
you can see we've got a brief narrative
up top to walk the students or the
learners through either a particular
problem or question or anything like
that but then down below we've got this
code zone and what this code zone is
is really a way to engage the learner in
like I said either exploring a new
function or answering a different type
of question so here then it says get the
list of words that have certain patterns
so now instead of starting with Z I'm
going to start with a and there we go
and it walks walks me through how would
answer this type of question or how I
would answer this type of scenario so
that's basically an overview of the
programming lab if you'd like to know
more information about it or have any
questions it's a little bit like um it's
not CBM exactly but it's the same
essence right it's sort of like you need
to stop worrying about the calculator
you've automated out of that and one
thing to think about math 25 years what
is going to happen in the current
scenario I think there are basically
three outcomes math will be run out of
business by a new subject which you can
argue is what I'm trying to do somewhat
except I would call it math that you
could cover it you know math math is the
traditional subjects in schools you know
can't exist in its current form it will
fail it is failing I mean it's just that
there's no way around that the question
is will it get reforms inside the
subject or will it be supplanted by some
other subjects no classics ran out of
business people don't do classics
anymore there was a time in the
nineteenth and early twentieth century
where people just couldn't believe that
you would not have a major subject in
schools of being classics but it did
slowly die and is now largely dead so
it's a snitch subject the same will
happen to math unless it gets reformed
and the cool thing is the people who
reformed first to this new kind of math
it's a bit like having a sort of
microcosm of universal education that
the British in particular had early
having universal education whenever you
do it is it's been a good thing I think
most people would agree having it being
first or being very early with it gives
you a real boost and I think Estonia for
example have understood that point and
others will slowly followed why now I
think it's important to understand
that's huge emphasis around the world
for this change
for a change people don't really know
what they need to change to you know
what they're doing is wrong and there's
ubiquity of devices and we have decent
interfaces to this the other way to
think about I mean Steve mentioned this
morning automation which has been a
thing I've pushed for many years as
being our core strength the real point
now is in a sense we and other people
have automated computation right i mean
so mechanized maybe will be a better
word you know 19th century people
mechanized you know factories got
mechanized physical machines could do
things people did physically now we have
machines that have found done a
fantastic job in automating calculating
and so the question is what you do in
education when you've when you've got
something that got got automated which
you were learning as part of your
education what do you do with it well
there are two ways you can handle it you
can say well you need to learn it first
before you use the machine or given that
the machine is now there and working we
need to learn something more different
we need to stand on the power of
automation in this case and go further
and that's what I'm arguing for stem and
that's what I think we have the ability
to deliver so the summary is for things
I think change the world's math
curriculum is one of our visions and and
practices and plans offer the best
support for today's stem curriculum have
coding be a follow-on have the Wolfram
language be the follow-on to scratch in
education I'll be a great thing to do
and I know we have a lot of support from
scratch folks like the ghost I'll
scratch Mitch Resnick and others are
very supportive of the idea of you know
at some point scratch which a lot of
people are using at an early stage kind
of runs out of steam and the question is
where you go then you go and use Python
I mean that seems like a crazy thing to
go and do I think we have a very nice
place to be there sort of Secondary
School where people can jump from
scratch into a sort of Wolfram language
thing and then also mix the math with
the coding and whether we should do
Wolfram assessment thanks very much